sujet suivant c'est celui de gérard
collomb alors la démission elle a été
présentée la confiance renouvelée hier
soir c'était le dernier épisode en date
du feuilleton gérard collomb un vrai
faux départ cependant puisque dans une
interview au figaro qui sera publié
demain mais qui hurle en ligne sur
lefigaro.fr le ministre de l'intérieur
de l'intérieur répète et maintient sa
proposition de démission on va voir tout
cela on va essayer de ne pas y perdre
notre latin alors elle est un peu cousu
de fil blanc ou pas cette affaire parce
que c'était la lecture jusqu'à 7
cette nouvelle ce maintien de la
proposition de démission puis voilà on
est là si c'est cousu de fil blanc ils
savent pas coudre
parce que moi il me semble que emmanuel
macron fait parfois piégé par son nez
obsession de la maîtrise des horloges
parce que à un moment où il aurait été
logique de changer de ministre de
l'intérieur a tous moi quand celui ci a
annoncé que de toute façon il voulait
arrêter tel moment
première occasion deuxième occasion ce
que je disais ici même sur ce plateau et
vous devez venons ce pas grave vous
entendre ils sont importants et la
pensée de giga mais il faut lui par sa
voir que votre pensée évolué j'ai médité
mon propos ici mais je suis aussi
rappeler la phrase de léon blum selon
laquelle on est condamné à se répéter ou
à se contredire et donc de temps en
temps je me contredis pour progresser et
deuxième occasion alors si ce n'est
occasions même quasi obligation à
déclaration à la presse comme quoi le
prix de la république plus personne ne
pouvait lui parler vraisemblable d'avoir
toléré qu'un mini disent qu'on peut plus
vous parler mais comme le démissionner
au moment où il a dit ça voudrait dire
qu'on l'a forcé à l'eau démissionner
veut être maître des horloges il ne fait
pas moyennant quoi votre truc cousue de
fils d'or dans le sujet mais sache c'est
carrément au grand guignol à la thèse
d'une mauvaise pièce de boulevard avec
des portes qui claquent à moitié des
surréalistes et à peu près
incompréhensible
ce qui est sûr c'est que effectivement
quand collomb a commencé à dire bon
finalement je compte pas rester
c'est vrai que macro aurait dû te suit
10 rebonds barreau charge il a fait pour
les raisons qu'à fort bien dit olivier
le choix inverse dire on le garde
et là dessus on sent que sa conduite mal
se passer parce que l'on continue de
critiquer peut être mécontent qu'on ne
l'ait pas dit de prendre la porte
conduit 2 christique et une fois deux
fois macro et puis arrive cet épisode
d'hier soir où que l'on nous fait savoir
qu' il a remis sa division au figaro que
macron a refusé sa démission et qu'il
faut que ça se sache tout de suite que
et on peut le dire si l'on dit pas nous
nous figaro d'autres le diront et que
d'ailleurs le président élise evans
confirmée et que d'ailleurs il est prêt
nous parler demain et on comprend que
c'est une opération de relégitimation un
peu bizarre un peu absurde qui consiste
à affaiblir quelqu'un pour dire qu'il
relie qu'il est reparti pour un tour
mais bon et qui va nous donner une
interview pour dire je suis là pour
rester j'ai plein de choses encore à
faire et tout bien pesé mon devoir me et
voilà ty pas que en début de l'interview
devait avoir lieu ce matin lieu cet
après midi
et cet après midi le journaliste
jean-marc leclerc et loire sauvestre est
que finalement il maintient sa démission
et que le miz de l'intérieur c'est
derrière lui qui ne veut pas être un
poids parce que c'est moi si c'est ça
qui l'épaulera c'est tout le temps ag je
rappelle libre et j'aime et je vois là
un défi je vois à l'écran je maintiens
ma proposition de démission
est ce que c'est ma proposition de
démission où ma démission
alors on a pris un titre volontairement
prudent parce que comme tout ça change
tout plongeur s'est notamment dit ça
mais quand on entend moi j'ai écouté la
cassette il parle pas c'est tout le
temps edit c'est un ministère et j'ai
adoré j'ai pris énormément de joie être
à la tête de ce ministère c'est quand
même nous reçoit avec l'actuel maire de
non pour dire qu'il est candidat à
nouveau la mairie de lyon donc il la
phrase n'est pas je démissionne mais
quand on lui dit venez donc vous
démissionnez dit pas non plus en fait
c'est qu'il s'en va et il ya un côté des
filles à mâcon qui lui dire je maintiens
ma démission maintenant tu fais quoi et
je pense que d'ici ce soir on va ça n'a
pas de sens parce que cette annonce est
déjà dite de grand public une
proposition d'émission déjà ça c'est pas
normal si vous voulez dire quand on
normal si vous voulez un soin n'y a pas
de problème soit vous vous avez un
problème vous allez voir le premier
ministre ou tara république et vous lui
dites ça va plus ça peut pas continuer
comme ça je veux démissionner et s'ils
prétendent république vous dites mais
non mais l'on lit
il faut rester vous sortez et voulant
dit de peau et ça ça s'est passé
plusieurs fois dans l'histoire de la
vème république
ou alors vous démissionnez personne peut
vous empêcher et kankan événement
démissionne on peut lui courir après des
mises aux points bas on peut pas
empêcher quelqu'un de bulletin de
l'électeur de maxime d'égailler de cet
épisode c'est une farce cerqueux et je
décorais que ce que dit olivier duhamel
en annonçant le fait qu'ils étaient
candidats à lyon de toute façon
collomb avait mis macron dans une double
impasse cercle où il le faisait
démissionner et n'était plus maître des
horloges et c'était la fin de la macro
ni historique
ou alors ils me maintenaient mais
c'était l'expression de sa faiblesse est
ce exact
alors pour essayer de d'échapper à cette
double impasse ils ont essayé de mener
une opération de religion mation qui
tourne en une farce est objectivement
enfin tout ça est assez catastrophique
on ne vit aujourd'hui ce gouvernement
que par la succession des démissions et
des problèmes de ressources de ces
primes de ressources humaines on en est
qu à massy démission depuis le début du
quinquennat de la part de ministres pour
des raisons diverses et variées je crois
que il ya quand même des vrais sujets y
compris au ministère de l'intérieur donc
tout ça je n'ose savoir ce que ce qu'on
pense ce qu'on pense réellement les
français et je crois que ça marque aussi
le manque d'autorité aujourd'hui d'
emmanuel macron faire qu'on ne court pas
après les ministres on va écouter juste
jérôme rephresh je voudrais juste qu'on
écoute parce que manifestement il
n'était pas parfaitement au courant des
derniers rebondissements edouard
philippe qui répondait aux questions
l'assemblée nationale en début d'après
midi
chaque ministre qui composent ce
gouvernement doit se consacrer
pleinement à sa tâche
j'ai connu comme vous monsieur ciotti
des membres du gouvernement qui à une
époque considéré qu'il était possible
voire permis d'être membres du
gouvernement et de solliciter un mandat
local parfois et même parfois monsieur
sauty présidentielle vous le savez
parfaitement je vous propose monsieur le
député de cesser cette hypocrisie
[Applaudissements]
oui d'abord gérard collomb n'était pas à
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi aux
questions d'actualité ce qui va
effectivement dans le sens d'une crise
politique disons le mot crise politique
car excusez moi quand même d'abord quand
colons commence par expliquer non poc et
le candidat aux municipales à lyon en
2020 c'est pas le sujet mais qu'il s'en
ira au lendemain des européennes c'est à
dire qu'il fixe lui même la date de son
départ on est là déjà dans une situation
profondément anormal deuxième chose je
rappelle qu'il y avait trois ministres
d'état dans le premier gouvernement
d'edouard philippe quelles sont ses
trois ministres d'état françois bayrou
nicolas hulot gérard collomb il ya donc
un problème général de la macro ni
politique qui ne s'est pas constituée et
qui se délite en partie il n'y a plus de
bonnes solutions pour emmanuel macron
dans la situation d'aujourd'hui
si nous avons le départ de colons comme
cela paraît très probable sauf à tourner
effectivement à une farce absolue comme
disait maxime des gayets
et bien évidemment mais on dira mais que
ne l'at il fait plutôt et il réagit en
fait c'est parce que l'on lui claque la
porte au nez
c'est ce qu'on dira et si collomb est
rattrapé par la manche c'est également
une situation c'est sûr content quant à
edouard philippe le premier ministre
dans cette situation une natte de
premier ministre que le nom permettez
moi de vous le dire il est d'ailleurs
curieux apparemment et d'enfiler parce
que là on a vu des images à l'assemblée
où donc il dit mais non que l'on est là
pour rester parce qu'il construira sans
pourcentage entre temps il apprend ce
qu'a dit en colombie au haut et au sénat
il est où décontenancé il dit bon bah
bah je prendrai mes responsabilités et
le président l'impliquant dans les
siennes et il est absolument furieux de
toute cette histoire parce que l'us je
crois comprendre que ça fait un moment
qui dit que c'est pas tenable et c'est
vrai que depuis roman de macron dit non
non le garde il va rester ça va bien se
passer
parce qu'il ne veut pas céder à la
pression et aussi parce qu'il n'a pas de
remplaçant tels que la question des
ressources humaines devient crucial
maintenant pourtant pour cette pour cet
avenir dira que qui ont ce tournant du
bas qui pour remplacer c'est vrai que
les poids lourds sont partie macro n'a
pas su agréger autour de lui d'autres
poids lourds
on parle en ce moment beaucoup de valve
sur 10 valls on parle de valse en
catalogne mais mais imagine voilà et
donc valls était mais imaginons pourquoi
valve et en catalogne
parce qu'on l'a piétiné qu'on l'a foutu
dehors aujourd'hui si matheron par
exemple avait su garder val dans un coin
et vas y aurait la carte valdes par
exemple pour l'intérieur aujourd'hui on
revient à dire est ce que ça va être le
désir s'est toujours fait ça bien sûr ce
déjeuner
aujourd'hui on tourne dit ah bah ça va
être l'audience que cette castaner
non tous les deux ans la personne c'est
par le nouveau monde sait si la personne
n'est pas certain que les personnes le
ski et le drame de la macro ni
aujourd'hui c'est que quand on voit que
et bien mâcon s'affaisse il n'y a plus
rien et ne sont que des ambitions
individuelles par scanner qui partent et
ceux qui s'épuisent ya ce qui s'explique
et puis on voit aujourd'hui les
ministres allaient les uns ou les autres
comme à paris être candidat aux
élections municipales donc on voit bien
que la promesse du nouveau monde qui
était un gouvernement
sonos d'experts qui serait engagée
pleinement pour régler le prennent des
français tout ça totalement imploser
deuxième remarque que je souhaitais
faire parce qu'on voit que les
situations politiques a fortement changé
c'est que le président de la république
avait visiblement moins de difficultés à
des maîtres à laval 4 étoiles que de les
mettre un ministre de l'intérieur
c'était il ya tout juste un an dans
cette histoire des pierres de ville et
on voit aujourd'hui qu on est dans des
élucubrations l'essai de tenir comme on
peut une maîtrise des horloges mais qui
fait qu'en réalité on s'enfonce toujours
un peu plus je crois qu'on va
effectivement vers une crise politique
parce que c'est l'implosion la macro ni
faux pas avec le terne crise on va vers
un délitement on constate en effet un
très grand c'est vraiment une crise une
crise de l'eau mais on se moque crise et
la tarte à la crème rampe à tout propos
moi je suis pour qu'on garde un sens au
mot en français une crise politique
s'est par exemple quand des frondeurs
déposent une motion veulent signer une
motion de censure oui et si elle est
votée s'ils avaient voté
là c'est la crise politique se déroule
un gouvernement renversé ça c'est une
crise politique
si à chaque faiblesse de la macro nous
ont dit qu'ils crise politique le
vaucluse n'a plus de sens oui mais
délitement en a un
oui c'est un monde très juste mais très
grave le modélisme
il signifie en clair que macro n'a pas
réussi à réorganiser le paysage
politique première remarque derrière sa
présidentielle alors que c'était l'un de
ses objectifs fondamentaux
fallait il n'a pas réussi à organiser et
allait agir sa majorité il voit partir
un certain nombre de soutiens
les trois ministres d'état excusez moi
excusez-moi duhamel mais les trois
ministres qui ont quitté ou qui ont été
sortis du gouvernement
c'est une situation exceptionnelle quand
même sous la vème république me
semble-t-il les trois ministres d'état
avec ce qui représentait politiquement
je n'ai donc plus loin et j'ajoute que
macron je termine si vous permettez moi
aussi ma phrase qu'a partir devant
demain contre les autres mais il est
intéressant
je ne dirais pas jusqu'à 10 bon enfin je
vous voyez ce que je pourrais dire je ne
dis pas mais on voit bien que macro qui
était amorcé une contre offensive est
cassé net dans la contre offensive qui
l'engageait alors certes délitement pas
crise politique mais un sacré
d'évitement quand même donc si vous
voulez mon origine et sa maman sa
démence est pas une pipe on que ces
plongeons alors même en complément ski
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans un tout
premier temps quand il était lui présent
la république ce monsieur qui ne
connaissait rien à l'art politique a
fait preuve d' art politique parce que
c'était très doux et en edouard philippe
et ce qui sauve deux avec il fait il ya
une initiative magistralement et
derrière il pense que ça suffit et il
laisse tomber l'action politique au sens
politicienne et c'est ça c'est
maintenant que lui même avait refusé
mais l'erreur il a cru à lui-même à ce
qu'ils racontaient aux français qu'on
entrait dans un monde nouveau où les
lois de la politique n'avait plus brillé
où ils avaient plus besoin de rallier
plus adorable vous avoir deux poids
lourds est con on est d'accord
otv quand même là l'internaute y disent
que
alors le chef d'état mais la question de
leur a été posée avant qu'on sache aux
derniers développements le chef de
l'état décidé de vous faire des
pressions sur mag à sa position sur
twitter donc selon vous emmanuel macron
at il raison de garder gérard collomb
non à 77% donc il était quand même un
petit peu ses adhérents s'étaient vu ce
que l'umq a répondu club pour laquelle
notre ami est habitué anti mac emmanuel
macron à tort de garder côlon avec lui
johan néanmoins colons peut-il partir
pana coordination non mais moi je vais
pas vous leur demandez dans une heure
emmanuel macron avec il eu raison de se
séparer de macron ils vont répondre au
mot la sese seko écolo qui sait pas mais
qui n'en semblent là vous mettez
emmanuel manar raison il n'a toutefois
pour les hôtels vous les années soixante
dix ans après ils sont assez équilibré
avec deux sont de moins en moins de son
maquereau mais très souvent ils
soutiennent des trucs dingues quand ils
considèrent que c'est bien c'est pas si
loin que ça c'est pas si ces listes
comment est époque tout à fait finie
mais c'est vrai que plus ça va mais
interview non mais plus ça va plus vous
ne sait plus à ceux plus ça se complique
pour mac os x raisons de lire le fameux
intéresse c'est exactement la même
olivier duhamel on me dit que emmanuel
macron dépêche vient de tomber
emmanuel macron vient de demander à
edouard philippe de lui présenter des
propositions bon voilà c'est le final
alors ça ça fait quand même des semaines
il faut faire un changement de
gouvernance et la vie dans un
remaniement au sérieux un jardin
gouvernement au maniement soyez
bon ça va nous attendre à ce que je
répète für eine que lydia que c'était
quand l'interview de colomb c'était
d'aller à l'express était ya quinze
jours trois semaines
à l'époque vous deviez non il peut
rester non non non les gens et là je
reviens au sentiment des français
je pensais au mobile ou que j'ai
commencé à dire qu'il fallait faire mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que au delà de
ces histoires de marty d'alliés de
structuration du jeu politique ce qui
dérange les français c'est qu'on leur
dise qu'un médiateur qui n'a pas envie
de faire le job l'aï dit c'est un truc
qui va pas et c'est suffisamment grave
et donc au delà c'est une action droite
et de gauche et des questions de mai où
les sujets qu'il ya devant les intérêts
sont tellement graves qu'il faut
quelqu'un de juste parce que ça prenne
ce tour pitra les les français s'en
foutent non et le problème c'est qu'à
force que sa deuxième ridicule mais la
mayonnaise son nouvel album et parce que
quand vous regardez ces derniers mois le
problème c'est que le pouvoir est tourné
sur lui-même
lesquels sont les trois pas crise mais
événements qui m'ont qui ont existé ces
dernières semaines c'est hulot benalla
colons à chaque fois c'est pas un
problème pour moi parce que c'était
l'histoire c'est pas un problème
d'orientation sépare grand débat sur
l'offre la demande et que l'état non à
chaque fois ce sont la confrontation
d'ambition que de désillusions de
rallier au parloir du petit témis en
tous genres des photos de travailleurs
et doit ce que c'est que ça les ennuis
de macron sans jamais sur ce qu'il fait
mais je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
comme la direction de l'express je sais
pas quoi prendre quand on se contente de
son vaisseau voir détruites et qu'on se
prend les clés